climate czar john kerry is dedicating
his
every waking moment to saving the earth
saving mankind and while he's doing that
he's polluting a lot he's polluting much
much more
than basically anybody else on earth but
it's it's very important that he do that
so that he can save the earth he has no
choice
on that issue pollution i understand
that you came here with a private jet
is that an environmental way to travel
if you offset
your carbon it's the only choice for
somebody like me
who is traveling the world to win this
battle
i negotiated the paris accords for the
united states
i've been involved in this fight for
years i negotiated with president xi to
bring president xi to the table so we
could get
paris and i believe
the time it takes me to get somewhere i
can't sail across the ocean i have to
fly
to meet with people and get things done
but what i'm doing
almost full time is working to win the
battle
of climate change and in the end if i
offset
and contribute my life to do this i'm
not going to be put on the defensive
i absolutely will not it's the only
choice for somebody like me you mongrel
you think i'm going to step foot in a
toyota yaris
do you think i'll step foot in a g4 for
goodness sakes
i'm not in the middle class g6 are bust
i have no choice
insists john kerry i'm michael knowles
that's the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back he has no choice my
favorite comment yesterday from
olivia v who says aoc encouraged
the blm rioters instructed them on how
to avoid arrest that's all true
so she needs to stop her whining about
the capital rioters well there's
certainly
a glaring double standard there maybe we
could learn something from the left
maybe we'll get to that
in just a little bit uh first we have to
prepare ourselves
to even see what the left is doing and
i you know i've just realized all year
long i have to be prepared that's why i
have
ready-wise ready-wise is the leader in
emergency food supplies
their emergency meals include
freeze-dried fruits and vegetables for
convenient
on-the-go nutrition and new adventure
meals
for hiking camping and other outdoor
activities
readywise products are proudly made in
the usa and they make being prepared
simple and affordable order
online and have nutritious meals shipped
directly to your doorstep
when preparing ready-wise meals all you
need is four cups of water
the water does not even need to be hot
you simply pour the food into the water
you stir you cover 15 minutes later the
meal is ready some meals
can even be prepared directly in the
pouch eliminating the need
for additional supplies if 2020
and early 2021 it's taught you anything
it should be that it's good to be
prepared
be prepared it's peace of mind this week
my listeners can get 10
off at readywise.com when entering
knowles 10 at checkout or by calling
855-453-2945 readywise has a 30-day no
questions asked return policy
there is no risk in taking the
initiative to get you and your family
prepared today that is readywise
r-e-a-d-y-w-ise.com
promo code knolls10 to get 10 off go
prepare yourself prepare your family for
any sort of emergency
go to ready wise
john kerry has no choice you see he is
on this salvific mission sort of a
divinely ordained mission
to save the earth and so he's look maybe
he's going to pollute a lot
a lot in the process and he's going to
get to enjoy lots and lots of luxuries
that he wants to deprive everyone else
from having
but it's all for the the greater good
because he
he is just so wonderful that he gets to
play by a different set of rules this is
a new hierarchy
he says i don't think it's hypocritical
at all i'm more special
than you are and so i deserve certain
special privileges
and these new hierarchies we're seeing
crop up all over the place
particularly with regard to left-wing
identity politics particularly in the
realm of race
there was this guy umair hock
don't know who that is he's the director
of the havas media lab he blogs at the
harvard business review
he's the author of the new capitalist
manifesto
building a disruptively better business
and he's some blue check mark
leftist who mouths off on twitter he had
a tweet that was a little bit radical
a little bit i say only a little bit
radical even by left-wing standards
yesterday he said quote
f off already white people you enslaved
and murdered whole continents
you have yet to make any amends and even
the good ones among
you i get this grammar's not not not top
notch
even the good ones among pretend that's
okay
we are still living in that world and it
makes the rest of us so so sick and
weary
and disgusted with you now of course
nothing not one single thing
that he said there is true uh he is
disgusted i don't know what has
disgusted him probably his sick ideology
but this is uh this is very wrong and a
sensible society
would ostracize this person right since
we're now in the business of deciding
who and
who ought to have this sort of public
speech on twitter and who ought not to
right right now we're in a world where
the duly elected sitting president
can't be on twitter but this guy can
that's crazy it should be the opposite
this guy should be ostracized
he should not be permitted in polite
company anywhere
but we now live in this world in which
they're
we're not permitted to make any comment
whatsoever about race unless of course
it is to attack whiteness which we are
told on the one hand is a social
construct and on the other hand we're
told it is so real that it is sort of
the dominant force and evil
in the world uh
this is of course the glaring
example as to why things like white
privilege or white supremacy are just
ridiculous because there is only one
racial group that you are not only
allowed to
condemn publicly but you're actively
encouraged to condemn publicly and that
of course is white people
doesn't sound very supreme or
supremacist
or whatever to me now you
see increasingly uh liberal
white people spouting this same kind of
nonsense there was a guy who went viral
on tick tock
explaining what a terrible oppressor he
is
because he's white yes exactly i
am the oppressor i am racist oh my god
he just said he's racist
it shouldn't be this hard you guys if
you live in america
went to school participate in the
socioeconomic structures participate in
any sort of system
education business entertainment what
have you and you are white
you are indoctrinated you are oppressive
and yes you are racist it is something
that we have
learned either consciously or
subconsciously all of us as white
americans
and what we have to do is unlearn that
i'm trying to do the work
part of doing the work is pushing
against dangerous narratives that are
counter-intuitive to that unlearning
like
white people are also oppressed by
racism we're not
we are the oppressors that's the point
you should be doing the unlearning too
do the work do the work he has
all of the cl it's almost like a parody
he has all of the
various characteristics of a sort of
liberal caricature
my first reaction listening to this guy
is
why should i pay attention to a word he
says he's a vile racist he's a terrible
oppressor
well if he really believes he's this
terrible oppressor how dare he
mouth off in public he needs to sit down
he needs to go away and
let other people who are of the more
blessed races or whatever
uh come out and and tell people what to
think he continues to oppress me with
his words
my second thought of course is that this
this kid couldn't oppress his own cat
you know he doesn't doesn't seem
particularly
particularly intimidating to me but he
is showing us something that the left
talks about a lot which is
that you'll hear the left describe
conservative women
as having internalized misogyny
so yeah they're women who contradict the
leftist feminist narrative
but we shouldn't listen to them we
should completely ignore what they have
to say because they are victims of their
own false consciousness
this is a marxist category a marxist
concept
that has existed for a very long time
you see the same thing with race you'll
say well we shouldn't listen to ben
carson we shouldn't listen to
clarence thomas we shouldn't listen to
tom soul we shouldn't listen to
any black person with whom we disagree
here on the left
because they have internalized racism
and this is usually used in a very
cynical way
however you know it's so it's so
preposterous that someone like this kid
could could be more conscious more aware
have higher faculties of reason than
clarence thomas you know
one of the greatest jurists of his age
or ben carson one of the most brilliant
physicians
in history you know first guy to
successfully separate
twins can join at the head right but but
no these liberal idiots they know so
much more they're so much more
conscious however there there is a
little something to it right which is
that this guy
is a white guy but he hates that he's a
white guy he hates
his identity because of his skin because
of this sort of
uh happenstance of his birth he he hates
himself and he feels bad and he
and he is clearly in a lot of angst uh
that's a big problem and it
is now being encouraged with the force
of the state you know there's
there's there is one example of legal
racial discrimination in the country
there's only one
and it's called affirmative action and
it disadvantages
white and asian applicants to
universities and it gives
an advantage to black and hispanic and
some other
applicants to universities a group of
asian students
sued harvard over this and the suit
didn't really go anywhere so during the
trump administration the doj
filed suit against yale yale has the
exact same practices and they
discriminate
against white and asian students and
it's funny because because we live in
the society where the
the only uh racial group that you're
allowed to
you know castigate in public as white
people usually this issue is framed
on the asian side of things but the doj
suit against yell did focus on they said
you're not only discriminating against
asians you're also discriminating
against
white applicants too so now that we have
a new presidential administration the
biden
doj came in they dropped the case
they said yeah you know whatever yale is
doing to white nation students
forget about it it doesn't matter and
and for a moment let's let's focus on
the asian students you know because i i
understand
there that whiteness in america evokes
all of these images because it's so in
our popular culture
but focus again first like we were doing
with the harvard suit focus again
on the asian aspect of it you now have
some
admissions officer at yale who's going
to call up you know some vietnamese
immigrants say i'm sorry mrs pham
i know you've been working very very
hard since you immigrated here
and i know you've made very low wages
and you've been slaving away
in some some menial job and you're your
son has been working very very hard to
do well on his s.a.t
to get into to get into yale but
sorry his spot has to go to someone else
maybe that other student is richer
maybe that other student has had more
advantages maybe that other student
comes from a more stable background but
he's got the favored skin color and your
student
mrs pham has a disfavored skin color and
so he doesn't he doesn't
get to go to yale sorry that's the way
things work
obviously deeply unfair we we can all
recognize that
as unjust anyone who is in the sensible
middle
all the way to conservative can
recognize that and yet
that is not just in the popular culture
that is not just something we're going
to overcome
by winning back the culture that is in
the law
that is a legal system of discrimination
that we have in the country some people
are the elect
some people get to play by a different
set of rules some people get
special advantages like john kerry
i you know that that white kid screaming
at all of us while he talks about
how white people are oppressors it does
kind of remind me of john kerry a little
bit
listen listen you can't i don't don't
listen to those oppressors just listen
to me
me john kerry goodness gracious do you
think john kerry has ever worked on his
own car
i don't think he has not a chance right
however you can work on your own car you
can get your own auto parts
and you can save a whole lot of money
doing so head on over to rock auto
that's a pretty good segue i like that
segue rockauto.com
is so much easier than walking into a
store and someone demanding quick
answers to things like hey
is your buick the xp5 or the 7z3 i don't
know what i don't know i just don't know
any answers to those questions i think
they only ask them to intimidate me
because they can tell by the cut of my
jib i'm not the most familiar with auto
parts then they go in the back
they go online they don't have the part
right so they go online they order the
the part probably from rock auto then
they charge me twice as much you can
skip
that hassle you have access to
rockauto.com at your desk or in your
pocket
the rockauto.com catalog is unique it's
so
easy to navigate that even i can do it
they have reliably at low prices they
have a phenomenal
selection they are a family run company
serving auto parts customers online for
20 years
which by my calculation is the entire
history of online shopping
just about so you can really trust these
guys go to rockauto.com right now
see all the parts available for your car
or truck then write knowles k
wlas in there how did you hear about
xbox so that they know we sent you
head on over great family company great
way to get auto and body parts
we love them go to rockauto.com
speaking of the official weight of the
federal government jen saki the white
house press secretary
continues every few days at least to
get one sort of slightly challenging
question
and one that keeps coming up is on joe
biden's catholicism
because joe biden says that he's
catholic but he doesn't act like he's
catholic he that this is why he was
denied the eucharist at a mass in north
carolina not so long ago
so they said okay hold on this guy joe
biden he's uh he's promoting all these
crazy gender theories he's promoting
abortion
how is he catholic gensake gives the
standard answer
you describe him as a devout catholic
will he use his faith to guide him in
any policy decision making
he does attend church nearly every
weekend and that's something that's
important to him personally
and to his family and he's talked about
the impact of his faith on healing and
everything he's been through
as a human being so certainly it's a
guide to him as a human being
what a creepy and weird answer
simple question does joe biden's faith
guide him
in his public life yes he goes to church
it guides him when he's at church yes
he does that right but religion is not
just about what happens from
8 to 9 a.m on sunday morning
religion is supposed to infuse your
entire life it is supposed to orient
what you do everything you do
has this ultimate goal of
knowing god and enjoying him forever to
quote the catechism
and she says no yes in this portion of
his life he's private he's personal
he's very catholic but in his public
life he's a complete degenerate
yes sunday morning he's really he's a
good little boy but the rest of the week
he's a complete derelict and this gets
to a story that we touched on a little
bit yesterday
marilyn manson's sex scandal and i know
it seems just like a kind of lurid
hollywood story
marilyn manson's sex scandal and the
kind of answer that gensake just gave on
religion
it actually gets to i think the central
political question that we're all
debating on the left and the right and
even within the right
which is what is liberty what does
liberty look like
so manson he's accused of abusing women
and most of the accusations against
manson by the way are
not that he you know went down a back
alley and ravaged some poor woman
it's that he was dating these women he
might have been engaged to a woman
but his behavior was nevertheless quite
abusive
uh there was an old guitarist who toured
with manson who said quote i'm sorry to
everyone on this podcast right now
who doesn't like this but that guy he's
amazingly talented but he's effed up
and he needs to be in check and he needs
to get sober and he needs to come to
terms with his demons
he is a bad effing guy i don't know if
marilyn manson did the things he's
accused of or not but you know there are
multiple stories
and he is the nation's highest profile
satanist so
you know seems plausible now you've got
this guitarist
who's saying it too very important he
says look he's yeah he's very talented
but look he's he's an addict he's an
alcoholic
he you know he's not totally in control
of himself he has demons and he needs to
needs to come to terms with that
he's a he's a bad guy yesterday
when we were talking about this we we
described how there are
goods that are higher than consent how
in kind of modern liberal society
we just say well you know look if people
consent to something
they can do whatever they want then it's
totally hunky-dory they can consent to
do the grossest
filthiest apparently most sinful things
in the world but as long as they consent
then we're all good right but the
marilyn manson stuff the actually the me
too movement generally
raises some questions here because the
the kind of abuse that
marilyn manson's ex-girlfriend was
describing where he's like tying her up
and beating her and yelling horrible
things at her
she consented to it i guess right she
said okay you can tie me up and do
whatever she
they did it a lot of times however it's
still wrong
even if they consent to it it's still
wrong so where this
brings us is to this central political
question
what is liberty you've got the kind of
modern lib version of liberty where they
say liberty is just being able to do
whatever you want you can do the
grossest filthiest
most sinful things in the world your
ability to be able to do that that is
liberty right our founding fathers
disagreed with this they made a
distinction between liberty and
licentiousness
they said yeah it's not it's not liberty
to go look at porn it's not liberty to
go
do sinful things but the modern lib view
is yes just do whatever you want right
the christian view of liberty and the
classic classical view even
non-christian view of liberty is
completely different the christian view
is
that the man who sins is a slave to sin
the christian view of liberty is that if
you do whatever you want if you if you
even do sinful things
not only is that not liberty that
actually destroys your liberty that
actually makes you a slave
and the non-christian classical view the
sort of ancient greek view talked to old
uncle aristotle
is extraordinarily similar which is that
we attain
liberty by practicing the virtues that's
why we educate ourselves this is where
the term liberal education comes from
you have to make sense of your liberty
you have to tame your base passions
you need to stop practicing advice you
need to start practicing virtues
and only then will you be fully in
command of yourself you're not a slave
to all your passions
and you can be free the
the classic example of this the perfect
example is the drug addict right
let's say you've got you've got a heroin
addict right according to the modern lib
view of
liberty his perfect freedom is to be
able to shoot up a bunch of heroin right
however if you think about a heroin
addict who's jones in for a for a fix
do you think that guy is free i don't
think so
i think if you go up to that heroin
addict who's really jonesing for
some more heroin and you ask him to do
anything
he'll do it because he he has
compromised his free will
he just he just wants the heroin he's
not in his right state of mind he's not
in control of himself
if you hold the classic sort of
christian or even classical
pre-christian
view of liberty then this modern
obsession with consent
doesn't make any sense because
and actually this is something the metoo
movement kind of understands they don't
know that they understand it but they're
kind of touching on it when
someone like evan rachel wood marilyn
manson's ex-girlfriend or some of these
other women or other women in the metoo
movement when they say
sure i consented to have the guy tie me
up i consent to dev and beat me i
consented to have him
scream terrible things at me i consented
to go to harvey weinstein's hotel room i
consented to do it again and again and
again
but he manipulated me he controlled me
he brainwashed me he tempted me with
hollywood
movie roles he i wasn't even though i
consented i wasn't
in control of myself i wasn't in
possession
of full liberty right
right this to me is the key this to me
is the
admission even by liberals and leftists
who don't know that they're admitting it
that the kind of modern fashionable
liberal view of liberty is just bs
because they're admitting they're saying
no in order for me to be truly free
i need to not be addicted to heroin i
need to not be following my base
passions i need to not be
degraded in this way i need to be i need
to be practicing virtues not pursuing
vices
i need i need to be in full possession
of my liberty
good i'm glad let's i hope conservatives
while we're
kind of you know skeptical of a lot of
the me too excesses
i hope we can take that lesson and point
it to the left and say right exactly
that the conservative version of liberty
is the right one
and that is why you don't get to do all
your crazy things that you want to do
that is that is why during the pandemic
during kovid
we should close the drug shops in san
francisco
and los angeles we should close the
marijuana dispensaries
and keep the churches open i know what
we've done is the opposite
what we've done is keep keep all the
head shops open and close the churches
but no we we can't do that that's not
what liberty is
that is not in the american tradition
that is not going to lead to flourishing
even you liberals are admitting it
right now this question of free will
keeps coming
up and up and up you'll you'll hear this
so much
from the biden administration you'll
hear this so much from really
any liberal government i think moving
moving forward
at least for the foreseeable future is
they're going to say look
we're not implementing crazy new
policies we're not transforming america
we're just going back to normal we have
no choice we are following progress
we you hear this when they mention the
right side of history
we are we are writing progress we can't
control progress
progress is moving in a predetermined
direction and you're either
on progress or you're standing against
progress
we have no choice we have to
pass all these pro-abortion laws we have
to do it it's progress
we have to grab much more power for the
federal government we it's progress
science
science is the other part of it it's
kind of the same thing but different
words
the science dictates you have to give up
all of your liberties
i have no choice i'm i'm just like john
kerry with the private jet i can't
i can't do the things that are
absolutely 100 demanded of me
by history and by progress and to save
the world
unless we follow this radical
leftist agenda joe biden is making this
point
explicitly you know he's been signing
what 40 some odd maybe more at this
point
executive orders he's making this point
explicitly from the oval
office he's saying i have
no choice you know folks
when we want to take back the culture
you've got to
engage you've got to participate in
conservative
institutions if you participate in the
liberal institutions you are going to be
following the liberal policies don't do
that break free of that
join daily wire okay you can get 25 off
a new daily wire membership with code
rhf
that is fading fast so you've got to
sign up today
watch our first feature film run hide
fight run hide fight
is uh opening the door into the
entertainment ventures that we're making
the critics absolutely hate it the
audience absolutely loves it
that's the kind of ratio that i want
head on over 25 off your membership
this promo is only available through the
weekend this is your last chance rhf for
25
off join the daily wire today we'll be
right back with a lot more
joe biden is not making new law joe
biden
is fixing bad policy what does that mean
absolutely nothing but joe biden says it
with a straight face
i want to make it clear there's a lot of
talk
with good reason about the number of
executive orders that i have signed
i'm not making new law i'm eliminating
bad policy
what i'm doing is taking on the issues
that
99 percent of them that the president
the last president united states
issued executive orders i thought were
very counterproductive to our security
counterproductive to who we are as a
country
particularly in in
the area of immigration i'm not making
new laws i'm
eliminating bad policy
as though the country is governed
by progressivism and liberalism
and then accidentally this guy donald
trump managed to make it into the white
house and that was
wrong and that was illegitimate and he
had all these sort of illegitimate bad
policies there
that joe biden is now going to undo
well that's not making a new law because
the the law the true law is liberalism
and progressivism
the illegitimate thing was what trump
did so he look look man 42 executive
orders now it doesn't matter
that's nothing because he's just
eliminating bad policy
obviously that's a meaningless statement
if you change the policies from the
previous administration you change them
when you go into office you are
effectively making new law
now what he's saying is look laws
they're made in congress
and and then i'll sign them and there's
that process i'm just doing executive
orders here but i'm not making new laws
and i'm fixing the policy well
more and more of our laws are made out
of the white house and the reason for
this
is that the actual institutions
that govern our country on a day-to-day
are the administrative institutions
which are executive agencies so the way
i've
this is why i defend executive orders
actually i don't defend his stupid
executive orders his bad executive wars
but i do defend good executive orders
because
if you want to harness the groups that
are actually governing the country
right now the way to do that is through
executive order
certainly more so than in congress
because congress is an absolute clown
show you know i called
this yesterday i called this yesterday
you know how much i hate to say i told
you so
but alexandria ocasio-cortez
came out and she made these big claims
she's been calling ted cruz and josh
hawley murderers
because she said they sent
insurrectionists to come murder me
at the capitol hill riot and she
she said you know i'm i'm a victim of
sexual assault this is the first time
we'd heard of this
and when i heard all these people coming
for me
i you know this was very traumatic and
cruz needs to resign now
and you say no aspect
no connection here between these random
thoughts
follows logic or is is persuasive in any
way
but i said look i wish that alexandria
ocasio-cortez were the kind of person
that i could believe but she is such a
pathological liar
she has been caught lying not just about
massive political questions
but even about her own biography she she
lied she pretended to
have been raised in the bronx she wasn't
she was raised in a very
fancy suburban town i know this because
i grew up in the town right next to her
the poorer town next to her at the same
time
i said i just can't believe her maybe
she could say a true thing but there is
no reason to assume that anything she
says is true
so turns out i was right
she said aoc that she was nearly killed
during the capital riot people were
yelling for her banging on doors coming
down the halls
turns out the person who was yelling for
her and banging on the walls and on the
door
was a police officer who was there to
protect her
here is the harrowing moment i
immediately realized that i shouldn't
have gone to the bathroom i should have
jumped in the closet
and so i i opened the door
when all of a sudden i hear that whoever
was trying to get inside
got into my office um
and then i realized that it's too late
that it's too late for me to
get into the closet and so
i go back in and i i hide back in
um in the bathroom
behind the door and then i just start to
hear these yells
of where is she
where is she and
i just thought to myself they got inside
they got inside
they hear that they're here now we know
we've seen on twitter
that they they've been around the
capitol and so now they've gotten inside
now how do we know that this person
was a rioter or was not a rioter why why
should aoc have known
that the person who was knocking on her
door was not a rioter
well uh that's because she wasn't in the
capital
aoc i should how did i not realize this
at the time
aoc was not even in the capitol
when the rioters entered she was in an
office building down the street
and i should have known this you know
members of congress spend most of their
time in
in office buildings that are not at the
capitol they're down the street
they're like a you know five to seven or
eight minute walk away from the capitol
now i figured well joint session maybe
she was in the capital
but we'd heard maybe they were evacuated
maybe she wasn't even there at the time
who knows
she was not there when they entered she
was not there for
any of it completely
made up and she has been saying now for
weeks that she was on she first said
that almost half of congress was killed
even though no members of congress were
even injured unlike say the
congressional baseball game when the
bernie bro almost killed steve scalise
she said she feared for her life she was
she had her life flashed before her eyes
all these sorts of things
she has been insinuating if if not
outright saying i i haven't followed
every statement she's made but she's
certainly been heavily insinuating and i
guess
implying you know necessarily she's
implying that she was at the capitol
that that she would have been there and
she wasn't
i understand that vanity
and dishonesty are occupational hazards
of politics
this is especially true of members of
congress
however this chickie is a
stone cold liar she
lies like a sociopath i've never seen
anything
like it even you know joe biden is
another one like this joe biden tells
lies like they're nothing this is why he
had to drop out of the 1988
presidential race because it's not even
the
kinds of lies he told joe biden never
went on tv and was
crying and saying this senator tried to
murder me and he didn't do that kind of
thing
but it was it was unsettling not because
of the
quality of the lies but because of the
ease with which he told them
joe biden will lie about anything like
it's second nature to him and it's
second nature to aoc
too there is no reason to believe
anything she says you know most i
know a good number of politicians and if
some politicians want to bend the truth
or they want to put some spin on which
you know goes with the territory
the vast majority of them that i've
known have not wanted to
outright lie that's always a rule don't
lie don't lie because
maybe you get caught in the lie and that
aoc doesn't matter
she will lie about anything which brings
us to
a question that the the left-wing media
are really trying to
to gin up and make the central issue
i don't even want to address it because
i think this is a trap i think this is a
complete
op by the liberal media and i think it's
so dishonest that i don't want to
address it so i'm going to speak
hypothetically here let's say
hypothetically and you can read between
the lines hypothetically
there's some kooky republican
congressman who says things that are
pretty kooky
kind of crazy sometimes right and this
congressman is a total backbencher
really has no power whatsoever and is
not a thing
and the only reason that anybody would
even maybe have heard this congressman's
name
is because cnn and msnbc and the
democrats
and left-wing commentators
keep trying to make a big deal out of
the kooky things this congressman has
said
do we think it is wise prudent
in the interest of the republican party
or the conservative movement or the
country
to take the bait and make a big deal out
of this person
i don't think so whatever kooky
crazy disreputable things this
republican hypothetical congressman
might have said
pale in comparison to things that aoc
has said
or ilhan omar or rashida talib or maxine
waters
or hillary clinton or nancy pelosi or
kamala harris all these people who have
actively encouraged violence
who have told people had actually our
favor my favorite comment from yesterday
mentioned this earlier
we we discussed it in the show aoc told
people how to avoid getting arrested
when they would go riot
maxine waters told people to commit
violence against republicans
kamala harris bailed out violent rioters
from left-wing
riots we never see the
left doing this sort of thing we never
see the left
taking the bait focusing in on their own
people have
wringing their you know clothing and
rending their garments and gnashing
their teeth over their own
major political figures to say nothing
over their minor political figures
it's it would seem that this is only a
big deal because the left is trying to
make it a big deal and let's say
hypothetically there's some kooky crazy
congressman and we get rid of that
congressman you know we totally come out
again we take the bait we make a big
deal out of it
do you really think that the left won't
just find somebody else
make us do the same thing to them there
might be some
practical politics we can learn here
from the left which wields
political power much more effectively in
this country than conservatives do
we might be able to learn some political
tricks without having to compromise our
principles or compromise our integrity
or compromise our morals
maybe we could just get a little bit
better at politics
but maybe we can't john kasich that's
enough of my hypothetical
a very hypothetical uh scenario here
john kasich
who is a liberal republican whose chief
strategist was john weaver
just mentioning that john kasich is now
going on cnn his job is to tap dance for
the liberal establishment his job is to
play the court jester
in the kingdom of liberalism he went on
cnn recently and said
that the gop will die if it remains
the party of donald trump rather than
say the party of
liberal squish john kasich i did so many
things down there that were conservative
and now these guys are off on some i
don't even know where they are they're
on
some crazy tangent here but that's
themselves power
but that's the point they are the
republican party now governor they
are the house republicans are very much
representative
of a very large chunk of the gop and
until they uh you know
unless they do something to say these
views are not okay and yes they're
speaking out but take action about it
then talking about conservative fiscal
responsibility and all those things
you know it gets drowned out don't you
think
i i dana i agree with that dana but
here's the thing
this gets back to what's going on inside
the party you know is it a trump party
is it not a trump party i will tell you
this if it stays at trump party in the
long term
it will not be successful it will begin
to die frankly it's been dying already
because a lot of people have left the
party
this coming from john kasich who you'll
recall
defeated donald trump in the 2016
primaries and then defeated hillary
clinton and became president right is
that what happened oh no it's not
trump beat kasich and then trump beat
hillary we were all told to remember
that no republican
was going to beat hillary we were told
hillary was going to win 99
with 99 certainty by some analyses when
trump got it
but even kasich does anybody really
believe that john kasich would have won
in the general election no of course not
but we're told if we don't ditch trump
and the sort of things that trump said
and stood for
and the kind of attitude that trump had
then we're going to die we're already
seeing people flee the party
donald trump did better among many many
voters than mitt romney did
well part of the evidence of this is
that romney lost and trump won
but even in 2020 when you look at those
exit polls remember we're told
trump is going to get blown out by the
white suburban women
they're fleeing though i don't know all
the white suburban women i know really
like trump but
we were told oh the white suburban and
he's going to lose among black voters
he's going to lose among hispanic voters
and he's going to lose among this and
lose among that
what happened do you remember from the
exit polls
trump gained with every
single voter identity group except for
white dudes
totally the opposite of what we're
hearing from the gop establishment
and listen to what uh cnn says to their
gelded little republican
john kasich i said look john your awful
party
if we want to get back to fiscal
responsibility discussions that will
permit
but we can't have trumpism you know we
can't discuss
immigration or manufacturing jobs
or bioethics or
a patriotism or you know anything that
actually matters
john it's perfectly fine for you little
castrati republicans to discuss fiscal
policy and tax cuts
but you you are not allowed to talk
about things that actually
matter to people that the left doesn't
like
this gets down to a battle for who is
going to lead the republican party we've
discussed over the past
week or two weeks that there's a fight
right now
for gop leadership in the house
a person who is in gop leadership even
though it's a small role to chair the
republican caucus
is liz cheney daughter of dick cheney
liz cheney voted to impeach donald trump
uh this was a very stupid vote uh there
was no reason this was
by the way i have to clarify because
trump was impeached two times both were
preposterous but the second one was even
more preposterous than the first
they impeached him for inciting an
insurrection obviously he didn't do that
we have we have it on tape before during
and after the insurrection he's saying
be peaceful don't
don't insurrect whatever but
because there was a riot they impeached
trump for this
the left actually incited riots and
encouraged riots and bailed out the
rioters prominent leftists one of whom
is now the vice president of the united
states
that nope no impeachment no removal no
censure but donald trump
doesn't do any of that and this lady liz
cheney decides to vote to impeach him
okay
stupid vote but whatever she that's her
conviction and she's got the courage to
carry it through
this is a very unpopular position in the
republican party and yet she's demanding
to remain
in leadership so there were big threats
to this matt gates was flying around the
country
saying we need to boot liz cheney out of
leadership
she's managed to cling to leadership
there was a vote last night
the vote was 145 to 61 house members
voted to keep her in leadership now the
key here is
it was a secret vote it was not
a public vote and this was the trick
that was always going to permit liz
cheney to remain in leadership i said
this
days ago i said liz cheney's probably
going to stick it out but it doesn't
bode well for the republican party
if this had been a public vote do you
think liz cheney would have won no no
way
because congressmen would have had to go
on the record and say yes
i want the politics of
impeaching the republican president over
nothing i want the politics of rolling
over for the left
i want the politics of returning to the
time when republicans lost and lost
and lost and frankly didn't even care
about most of the issues
that the base cares about
that vote would have been unacceptable
to a huge portion of the gop base there
would have been a lot of primaries
and so that's why they had to conduct a
secret ballot because now we don't know
who voted for and who voted against i
bet if you
if you took republicans and trotted them
on republican members of congress and
trotted them on the sunday shows
and asked each and every one of them did
you vote
to keep liz cheney in leadership you'd
see those numbers change dramatically
you'd see
numbers at least flip i think you would
not have 145 republican congressmen
coming in saying yes
i support liz cheney but
they've kept her in this position and
this is only going to allow
the the divide to fester a lot a lot of
it getting down to the things we've been
talking about
what is liberty are we going to be a
party that just
stands for nothing you know we have no
substantive vision we just stand for do
whatever you want
and the only thing we can all agree on
is tax cuts but otherwise we can let the
left
impose their moral vision on the country
that's kind of the old way of the last
20 years
it's not even the old way of the last 50
years conservatives used to have a
backbone they used to stand up for this
sort of thing last 20 years they kind of
lost their gumption
or are we going to be the party that has
a substantive moral vision that has
a actual political plan for the country
and that's willing to wield power
if we can't resolve that question if we
can't resolve it in the right direction
then the left is just going to keep on
keeping on and they're going to be glib
and they're going to be
shallow and they're they're they're it's
going to be the
the party of gensake you know the white
house press secretary but they are going
to continue to govern it's going to be
the party of joe biden
where he says i'm not doing anything new
i'm just returning to normal and
progress is going to move forward
you saw this jen jensocki said this the
other day she was asked a question about
space force this is a branch of the
united states military
that was announced under president trump
obviously trump didn't
come up with the plan for space force
this has had been in in the plan
in the works for many years and jen saki
was asked hey what's going on with space
force
and her answer was to giggle and just
make a glib comment
deriding this entire branch of the
military
soon they asked whether the president
has made a decision on keeping or
keeping the scope of space force wow
space force it's the plane of today
um it is an interesting question um
i am happy to check with our space force
point of contact i'm not sure who that
is i will find out and see if we have
any update on that
wow oh look at that listen to this guy
he's talking about space force next
year's going to be asking about the navy
i don't know what hey that when i handed
you guys all out the list of questions
that you were permitted to ask me
her royal highness you that wasn't on
there so get a load of this guy
yeah no whatever it's kind of an
interesting question i'll circle back
because i don't have the answer to
anything
so this didn't play very well even among
democrats this was a little bit too far
so jen saki was asked to apologize and
of course she
did not the top republican on the house
armed services committee is asking you
to apologize for some of the comments
that you made yesterday in the briefing
room about the space force
will you apologize i did send a tweet
last night you may not all be on twitter
maybe they're not on twitter that said
we
invite the members of space force here
to provide an update to all of you on
all of the important work they're doing
and we certainly
look forward to conceiving continued
updates from there from their team
big picture here i mean does the space
force have the full support
of the biden administration or is the
president at some point perhaps going to
try to get rid of it
or in some way diminish it they
absolutely have the full support of the
biden administration
and we are not revisiting the decision
to establish the space force
the desire for the department of defense
to focus greater attention and resources
on the growing security challenges in
space
has long been a bipartisan issue
informed by numerous independent
commissions and studies conducted across
multiple administrations no apology of
course just this kind of
slightly toned down but still similar
glibness
yes we've invited the space force so
they can give us an update if they want
uh yes it was in the works for years
it's absolutely fine and no i'm not
going to apologize
because i am going to play by a
different set of rules i am the elect
listen to me how dare you how dare you
ask me to apologize
how dare you ask me to apologize for my
private jet
don't you know who i am i have no choice
the arrogance the absolute
evasion of accountability that is
that is government by the anointed at
least as far as they see it
uh but it's not inevitable we do have a
choice if we can figure out
what exactly our free will what exactly
our
traditional american liberty is what it
actually means and how to use it
i'm michael nolis the michael knowles
shall see you tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadofsky editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coramina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator mckenna waters
the michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire
2021 today on the ben shapiro show
alexandra ocasio-cortez was not
in the main capitol building during the
january 6th riot but her story is still
the one leading the news and the fact
checkers are defending her
against all adversaries that's today on
the ben shapiro show tune in